This is really an interesting one,
I think.
I mean,
so I don't know what God's doing here
exactly,
but he's helping ignite the sacrificial
flame and that's kind of an interesting
idea I think because you know,
let's say that you have an impulse to
make a sacrifice.
You think,
well,
I should change this about my life.
What?
What's like?
Where does that come from?
That impulse is just,
well just manifests itself out of
nothing.
So what order you came up with it,
well,
you might want to start thinking about
that thinking so surely that you come up
with your own thoughts.
You don't come up with your damn dreams.
Do you pay just happened and God only
knows where they come from.
They come from your brain.
Whoa boy,
that's a sophisticated answer that come
from your unconscious.
Well,
that's not much better.
At least it's somewhat better,
but there are those matt,
amazing dramas take place in the theater
of your imagination at night.
You don't even understand what they are
and yet they occur night after night and
those things,
dreams,
they can contain wisdom that it just.
Well,
it just staggers the person who has the
dream.
Once they get the key to the dream,
once they remembered,
it's like,
oh look,
you just revealed a bunch of wisdom to
yourself that you didn't know what.
Where'd that come from?
Well,
you don't know.
How in the world can you dream up things
that you don't know?
That's a tough one.
Maybe we'll talk about that at some
point in this lecture series because
there are some reasonable things that
can be said about that,
but you know the idea of that
there's something that's not you young
would call it the self.
Carl Jung would call it the self,
which he thought of it as the totality
of your being across time and space.
It's something like that and that you
know each second that you exist is a
slice of the self manifesting itself
across time and space,
and he thought of the.
The self is partly the voice of
conscience.
Whatever that is that helps guide you
when you have to make a difficult
decision and a difficult decision might
be,
well,
what do I need to sacrifice?
What is,
how do I need to discipline myself,
right?
What do I need to forego?
Well,
how do you figure those things out?
you know,
we'll just picture is trying to put
forth the idea that perhaps if you had
established the proper relationship with
God the father and we've talked about
what that might mean,
then he would help figure out how to get
this sacrificial fires burning so that
you could stay in a proper relationship
with him across time.
Well,
if that's such an unreasonable
proposition,
it.
What's the alternative proposition?
Well,
this isn't working out very well,
that's for sure.
You know,
Kate seems to be doing it.
I don't know what it is.
It's like he says,
if he thinks he can only do it himself
or maybe he wants only to take credit
for it or something like that,
he's not in this
grateful,
let's say,
and inquiring grateful and inquiring
posture because that's what a prayer for
posture should be.
It should be grateful and inquiring and
grateful is,
thank God things aren't worse for me
than they are and you should be grateful
about that because they could be a lot
worse than they are and they can be so
bad and inquiring would be,
well,
I don't really know how I could make it
better,
but I'm.
I'm open to suggestions,
man,
if I can figure out how to do it all,
try it.
That's the.
That's the humility and the inquiry.
That's a humble inquiry.
How could I make things better?
It's something like that and that's what
sacrifices do I need to make in order to
make things better.
That's a good question to ask yourself.
You could ask yourself that every
morning,
what sacrifice do I have to make to make
things better?
You can decide what constitutes better.
How about that?
Then it's not even as if it's being
imposed on you.
Come up with your own notion of what
constitutes better.
Try to make it sophisticated.
Should just be better for you because
that isn't going to work very well.
Right?
You're.
You're just gonna fall downstairs.
If you do that because you have to live
with other people and besides stupid
anyways,
what are you going to do like can't even
just nothing you could even say about
that.
It's so that that's the.
That's the attitude of a very badly
behaved hyper aggressive two year old
and I mean that technically and so you
could.
You could ask yourself,
well,
how I have this day that lays itself out
in front of me?
What thing could I let go of that's
impeding my progress that if I let go of
would make my life better,
my family's life better,
my culture's life better,
my being better,
and then that would give you something
to do for the day,
wouldn't it?
Into a justify your miserable life
because you need that.
That's the whole point of the first
story of Adam and eve.
What do you have?
A miserable life?
Okay,
what am I going to do about that?
Well,
if you just have a miserable life,
you're just going to suffer stupidly and
get bitter about it.
That's what happened is to cane.
It's like,
well,
how about not doing that?
Because that seems to just take a bad
deal and make it worse.
How about making a sacrifice and seeing
if you can please God and put being on
track?
God,
that'd be something to do.
What could be better than that?
What could possibly be better than that?
Well,
that's why it's archetipal band because
nothing's better than that.
That's where tops out.
So when you can do that,
you could do that every day.
You'd have to do it in a little way
because like what good are you?
You know you're not going to go and
bring this socialist utopia in to being
in one fell swoop.
You might also think that one of the
things came might figure out here.
There's a couple of things that just
aren't going right for him,
downwind of the fire,
not the right place to blow from and the
fact that he's in hidden valley in Hays
and smoke and breathing it in and the
fire isn't burning.
Might be an indication that he's doing
something wrong or he could be wiping
his eyes and say,
Jesus,
what kind of stupid bloody universe
would produce smoke like this?
It's like,
yes,
well that's the more likely outcome,
and the Lord said unto Cain,
why Art Thou wroth and why is they
countenance fallen?
If Thou knewest well Shalt Thou not be
accepted?
Now that's an interesting line because,
and I've looked at a variety of
different translations of.
This is seventh verse here,
like a bunch of them,
because the translation for that,
that's a critical line and the
translation really matters and so I'll
tell you what I think the story is what
I've been able to figure out,
and I'm sure I haven't got it completely
right,
but it's so he asks,
God says to him,
if you do well,
won't you be accepted?
What does the hint there?
Right?
It's something like,
well,
things aren't going so well for you,
so the first thing you might think is
you're not doing well.
What does that mean?
You're not doing good?
Does that mean you're not acting
properly means it's the hint because God
is suggesting that if you are doing it
properly,
you would be successful.
I had a friend at one point who was a
very bitter person and he had a bunch of
problems and some of them were self
inflicted in some of them were fate,
I suppose that he had.
He was,
he had become very,
very destructive,
murderously,
destructive,
genocidally destructive.
I would say.
You could see it in his dreams and,
and he lived with me for awhile and I
knew him very well.
He was a friend of mine from the time I
was 12 until the time he committed
suicide when he was about 40 and a
when he lived with me.
I was trying to help him get on his
feet,
which was why he had come to live with
me because he thought maybe I could help
him get on his feet and he could only
take relatively low level jobs.
You know,
like he had some mechanical ability,
didn't,
he didn't get educated.
Although he's a very,
very smart person.
He probably had an Iq of about 135 or
something like that.
He's very smart and so he was bitter too
because he hadn't educated themselves to
the level that his,
you know,
his intellectual,
abandoned.
So we had to take jobs that were beneath
him intellectually and he had a,
he had that real intellectual arrogance,
you know,
because he was smart and really smart
people often come to believe that only
smart matters and if they're smart and
all that and all it matters is smart and
then the world isn't sort of laying
itself at their feet than they've been
terribly betrayed and,
and then they cling to their
intelligence,
which is more like a talent or a gift.
Like it's a,
like it's an idol,
you know,
a false idol,
which is exactly what it in a very
dangerous one and get cynical about the
stupidity of the world and the fact that
their are talents weren't properly
recognized.
And that's just not that helpful because
smart is a good thing.
But I'll tell you,
if you don't use it properly,
it will devour you.
Just like all arbitrarily assigned
talent.
Right?
So you might have a talent,
but it's your friend if you use it
properly.
And you misuse it,
it will be your enemy,
and maybe that's how God keeps the
cosmic scales adjusted.
But anyhow,
my friend was a very smart person,
although not as smart as he thought he
was unfortunately,
and,
but he hadn't done what would have been
necessary with that intelligence to make
it manifest itself properly in the
world.
And that also embittered him because he
also knew that there was more that he
could have done if he would have done it
and perhaps more that he could still do
what I was suggesting to him while he
was living with us because he was,
you know,
two levels from homeless by that point
was that he should find a job that he
could find working in a garage,
working in a shop,
something like that because he had some
mechanical ability and that he should
do.
He should separate himself from the
arrogance that made him presumed that
such a job would be beneath him because
at that point no job was beneath him.
And,
but more importantly,
it's not so obvious that jobs are
beneath people,
you know,
because even if you're a,
even if you imagine you have a job as a
checkout person in a,
in a grocery store,
you know,
as a fairly unskilled job,
you can be some miserable,
resentful,
horrid bastard doing that job.
Boy,
you know,
you can come in there just exuding
resentment and bitterness and making
mistakes and making sure that every
customer that passes by you has a
slightly worse day than they need to
write.
And,
and you know,
pilfering time and perhaps pilfering
goods and being resentful about the
people who,
who gave you the position because
they're above you in the dominance
hierarchy and talking,
you know,
bad things.
Gossiping behind the back of your
coworkers is like,
you can take your menial position self
described and turn that into a very nice
little slice of hell.